bonjour je m'appelle camélia rachedi
j'ai 16 ans et suis lycéenne
j'ai toujours habité avant juin les
habitant de vaulx en velin
on les appelle les vaudais du coup je
suis vaudaise fait partie d'un projet
qui s'appelle paul is it et c'est une
action recherche qui vise à améliorer
les relations entre la police et la
population
plus précisément les jeunes mais tout
d'abord aujourd'hui je suis venu avec un
sac à dos et dans mon sac à dos j'ai des
souvenirs
mon premier souvenir
ces jeunes filles de six ans qui joue
par son balcon et qui regarde autour
d'elle et qui se prend pour une
princesse parce qu'elles pensent que les
tours autour d'elle c'est une forteresse
qui la protègent et cléguer les jeunes
c'est des gardes qui sont là pour la
protéger aussi je vous livre ce souvenir
parce qu'à six ans on comprend pas
forcément comment les gens peuvent voir
notre quartier notre ville autrement que
nous mon deuxième souvenir c'est une
jeune fille de 16 ans qui sort du lycée
un jour et qui se rend au centre social
georges lewi avant juin en entrant dans
le centre elle sent une ambiance un peu
tendue
il y avait une cinquantaine de jeunes
filles et garçons mélangés un peu plus
de garçons et un gendarme
et quand ils sont arrivés le gendarme
est venue après
quand le gendarme est arrivée les jeunes
y ont dit ces boues le policier c'est
vous le jardin et après ils ont discuté
pendant une heure une heure et demie et
en sortant ils ont tous dit aux
gendarmes
au revoir monsieur je vous dis ses
souvenirs pour montrer que si on est
respectueux avec les jeunes
si on dialogue avec eux ils savent être
respectueux et savent discuter mon
troisième souvenir c'est encore une
jeune fille de 16 ans qui en allant au
lycée elle traverse la route et en
milieu du passage piéton et à une
voiture de police qui arrive et qui
l'insultent vous voyez le groupe de rap
des années 80 ldm vers c'était ça la
suite
cette jeune fille n'a pas réagi
l'ap a répondu à la provocation et elle
a continué sa route
je vous livre ce souvenir pour montrer
que c'est grâce au projet policiers et
grâce à tout ce qu'on a fait avec le
groupe que ce jour là j'ai pas réagi et
j'ai continué ma route
le projet politique et il est né au
centre social georges lewi au départ et
s'appelait le projet discrimination
parce qu'on voulait savoir ce qui était
une discrimination
comment savoir si on était discriminer
si on avait déjà discriminées quelqu'un
pour savoir tout ça on a dû aller à
l'unité peut faire des réunions avec des
chercheurs de la ltp annaïck turenne et
marine huer quand on a su tout ce qui
était discrimination si on avait fait si
on n'avait pas fait on a organisé des
entretiens avec des personnes ayant un
rapport à vanves l'un ou ou qui habitent
à avant blanc durant ces ces entraves et
ses interviews
on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
beaucoup de problèmes entre la police et
les jeunes
et comme je vous racontais dans mon
souvenir quand je suis arrivé au centre
et qu'on a discuté avec l'agenda
le gendarme il nous a expliqué nos
droits nous de voir ce qu'on avait le
droit de faire et est ce que les
policiers avaient le droit de faire ce
qu'ils n'avaient pas le droit de faire
et ça nous a beaucoup aidés parce que ça
a été un déclic ne savait pas forcément
ce qu'on avait le droit ou ce qu'on
n'avait pas le droit de faire et on
savait pas que les policiers ils
n'avaient pas droit de tout faire
du coup avec le projet on a des
correspondants à montréal nord et eux
ils ont aussi des problèmes avec la
police les jeunes et pour remédier à ça
ils ont fait une carte des droits on
s'est inspiré de leur carte des droits
pour faire la nôtre
une carte des droits c'est un petit
prospectus qu'il plie petit comme ça et
qu'on peut porter sur soi à l'intérieur
il ya comment se comporter en cas de
contrôle que faire si c'est un contrôle
abusif et à qui il signalé quand on a
fini cette carte des droits on a
organisé une conférence avec à peu près
de 100 personnes dans cette envie et
cette conférence a été vraiment
importante pour nous parce que à ce
moment là on arrive voir si ça allait ça
avait de l'impact si les gens
s'intéressaient
à ce qu'on faisait et puis une semaine
deux semaines après on avait des
articles un peu partout des journaux
locaux régionaux et nationaux et on sait
déjà mais quand même ça touche les gens
et les gens ils se rendent compte que
c'est un problème qu'on rencontre tous
les jours
à ce moment là le chercheur à nous
parler un peu du canada et au canada il
ya beaucoup de discrimination envers les
indiens
du coup on a fait venir un chef indien
au centre social et quand je suis arrivé
j'ai dit bonjour et il m'a répondu annie
cb ou 1h et b sait plus trop c'était
quoi le mou mais je me rappelle du sens
ça voulait dire fille de mon peuple et
sa facilité de dialogue on a pu
dialoguer l'expliqué nos discriminations
ce qu'on ressentait ce qu'il ressentait
comment il a fait pour s'en débarrasser
et ça nous a aidés dans le projet parce
que c'était les premiers pas ou ont
commencé à avoir des dialogues avec les
gens un jour en arrivant à la réalité
peu une des chercheurs nous à nous a
fait montre et on nous a montré une bd
cette bd
à l'intérieur il y avait comment les
quartiers populaires étaient représentés
au journal télévisé et nous s'est dit
pourquoi pas faire notre vie d'annie où
on mettrait notre recherche les effets
que ça a eu sur nous tout ce qu'on a
fait et comment on a réussi à parler et
à travailler avec la police
du coup pour faire cette bd il nous
fallait des fonds on a fait une demande
de fonds à la fondation vinci qui nous a
accordé les fonds et ça commence à se
mettre en place on a des dessinateurs
des limicoles de l'école emile cohl et
et on commença à travailler
du coup nous cette expérience elle nous
a fait grandir parce qu'on a appris
beaucoup de choses comme le droit comme
comment se comporter et et on est monté
à paris au ministère de l'intérieur et
on a rencontré le conseiller de police
de gérard collomb qui était très
enthousiaste à notre projet qui qui
était qu'il voyait qu'eux on
s'investissait et qui nous a dit que
c'était super bien mais qu'ils pouvaient
pas nous aider si nous on travaille est
pas au niveau local du coup on y rentre
avant là on a organisé une rencontre
avec la commissaire au tout début de
cette rencontre on parlait tout
doucement on avancer doucement
et puis au bout d'un moment on a réussi
à imposer nos problèmes et que pose leur
problème et là on travaille avec eux
c'est quand même un progrès non et du
coup là ces vacances on est parti à
londres avec le projet on a rencontré
des policiers des jeunes des
associations et ce qui nous a marqué
c'est que il travaille tous ensemble
en fait que ce soit les policiers les
jeunes et des jeunes qui font des
patrouilles avec des policiers et nous
saisit mais sont en quelle année parce
que s'il y avait ça en france il aurait
pas autant de problèmes
ce voyage il a été financé par là par la
fondation open society et moi ce que je
veux faire retranscrire à travers ce
témoignage c'est jeu que les ados qui
n'habitent pas à vos qui ne vivent pas
ça tous les jours s'en rendre compte
et sache que ça peut arriver à tout
moment je veux que les adultes qui
n'habitent pas à vaulx en velin qui ne
voyais pas ça non plus
l'entente de la bouche d'une jeune et en
prennent conscience aussi vu que les
adultes devant en velin soient fiers de
leurs jeunes et qu'ils disent que c'est
pas que des petits gamins qui font
n'importe quoi dans la rue
vu que les adolescentes vaulx en velin
croit en pole ici tu es et croit en nous
et croit en la solution aujourd'hui
s'unit avec enfin il ya des membres du
projet qui sont venus voir et j'aimerais
qu'ils montent avec moi au jour
d'aujourd'hui et même les dessinateurs
donc s'il vous plaît à vanter les
appliquer
[Applaudissements]
et du coup avec le projet ce qu'on
voudrait faire nous c'est la police elle
est là et de ce qu'on veut faire c'est
sa merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]